bonjour je suis fabienne
labrette-ménager je suis consultante en
marketing territorial et je suis élu de
la sarthe depuis plus de 20 ans je suis
vice président du conseil départemental
en charge du logement et je suis
également maire de fresnay-sur-sarthe
depuis 2004 l'ex j'ai choisi d'être
candidat sur la première circonscription
de la sarthe pour plusieurs raisons
parce que j'y vis j'y travaille j'ai
élevé mes enfants tu vois au quotidien
et puis parce que j'ai été aussi le
député de 2007 à 2012 à travers mes
mandats connais vos difficultés je sais
que nous avons des défis à relever
notamment l'accès aux soins pour tous le
maintien des commerces de proximité
le maintien des écoles de proximité le
maintien des services de proximité
alors c'est tout naturellement que j'ai
choisi d'être candidat de la droite et
du centre parce que je ne renie pas mes
convictions parce que je veux défendre
mes idées et qu'en même temps et bien je
sais qu'à l'assemblée nationale
puisqu'on unis pour pouvoir défendre le
territoire qu'elles soient ruraux qu'ils
soient urbains où qu'ils soient des
rurbains je compte sur vous en juin
prochain merci
[Musique]